la majorité d'entre nous n'avons aucune
idée concrète de ce qu'il nous faut
réellement pour être heureux et ce même
après avoir validé les étapes
successives de la vie d'un adulte
accompli j'entends souvent ce genre de
discours tu vois mathilde j'ai tout j'ai
un travail qui me permet de bien gagner
ma vie j'ai une voiture j'ai une maison
chez un chat un chien j'ai cours d'une
famille je me suis marié
dans l'autre sens on est allé à
disneyland cet été et puis je me suis
acheté le dernier robot thermomix qui
fait la cuisine à ma place même si ça
m'a coûté un mois de salaire
pourtant il manque quelque chose quoi
alors dans la salle aujourd'hui soyons
honnêtes entre nous et j'aimerais que
vous leviez la main si vous avez
l'impression que vous êtes à la quête
d'une sorte de plus grand bien je vous
regarde
ok pour ça fait beaucoup
ça va bien mais c'est bien parce qu'à la
fin de ce tome vous allez vous rendre
compte que en fait alors inutile de vous
dire que ça sert à rien de contempler la
signification cosmique de votre vie
assis sur votre canapé à manger les
bretzels
il faut passer de spectateurs à acteurs
et alors je me dis moi le bonheur je les
trouvais à travers mes voyages
parce que je me suis rendu compte qu'en
fait on vit dans un monde drôlement
paradoxale où d'un côté on prend tout
pour acquis et de l'autre on est
constamment satisfaits et mes voyages
m'ont permis de me rendre compte des
choses qui sont vraiment importantes
pour moi des choses qui me font vibrer
de ce pourquoi je me lève le matin mes
voyages m'ont permis de relativiser et
de me dire en fait le bonheur je l'ait
déjà et m'ont permis de dire oui je suis
heureuse parce que je le vaux bien
alors mes voyages permis de me
reconnecter avec certaines valeurs
qu'ils trouveront un peu disparu la
société d'aujourd'hui
j'ai redécouvert ce que c'est que le
partage
je voyage aux philippines j'étais dans
un bus et j'avais chaud j'avais faim et
tout d'un coup on s'arrête dans une
citation au milieu de nulle part et il y
avait ces dames à l'extérieur dans les
paliers n'en restait pas dans les
paniers
ouais je dis ouais je m'en vais ok donc
elle vendait des trucs dans les feuilles
de banane voilà vous savez et alors la
dame qui était assise à côté de moi il
en avait pris et elle dépliait ça d'une
manière super méticuleuse pour
finalement découvrir à l'intérieur des
boulettes de riz gluant mets
appétissants qu'elle décroche et et
qu'elle donnait à ses quatre petits
garçons qui étaient éparpillés un peu
autour de nous avec les poules de toutes
les couleurs et c est en voyant mon
regard sur son épaule d'un geste tout à
fait naturel elle en a décroché un bon
et elle me l'a tendu et son geste m'a
surpris et le plus surprenant c'est que
son geste mais surpris j'ai redécouvert
ce que c'est que la sécurité
je vivais à cape town en afrique du sud
et un jour je me suis dit bon c'est pas
très grave si je quitte le travail et
6h15 plutôt qu'à six heures ça voudra
juste te dire que le soleil sera tout
juste coucher mais bon et alors en
marchant dans la rue vers les petits
mini bus qu'elle aime ramener chez moi
sur le trottoir d'en face deux hommes
arrive et me dévisage d'un regard noir
alors j'avais une espèce de boule au
ventre et en passant près de moi il y en
a un qui me tape sur l'épaule et qui me
dit ces trois mots ue à white
c'était pas une menace ça voulait juste
dire toi là à cette heure si tu devrais
être chez toi et je me suis rendu compte
de ce que ça fait que de pouvoir sortir
s'en préoccuper de l'heure qu'il est
s'en préoccuper du fait que je sois une
jeune femme de couleur claire et de même
pouvoir faire ce geste tout naturel qui
est de prendre mon téléphone pour y
répondre sans avoir peur je me suis
rendu compte de ce que c'est que la
vraie générosité
quant au début de cette année j'ai
entamé un projet un peu fou avec un ami
à moi allemand c'est peut-être pour ça
alors on a décidé de venir en aide à une
petite école dans l'ouest du kenya qui
offrent l'éducation totalement gratuite
à 200 orphelins du village alors on
s'est dit si on va monter un projet on
va appeler ça chip inpact à nous deux on
à 3000 euros on est en afrique du sud
alors ce qu'on va faire
on va traverser l'afrique du sud le
zimbabwe la zambie le malawi la tanzanie
l'ouganda pour arriver jusqu'au kenya en
stop 5200 km ça nous a pris trois mois
et un an exactement 94 jours nous avons
payé pour dormir quatre nuits parce que
quand même on essayait de se faire
offrir le gîte et le couvert
surtout le gîte et pour économiser tous
ses sous et alors en fait on a dû payer
ces quatre nuits là uniquement parce
qu'on s'était retrouvés dans le fin fond
de la brousse tanzaniennes et que
c'était devenu impossible pour nous
d'expliquer aux locaux quelle était la
nature du projet et que de toute façon
aussi mérité bien notre contribution
on est arrivés sur place avec 3 millions
grâce à nos amis à notre famille à tous
ceux qui ont entendu parler du projet
sur les réseaux sociaux et sur notre
site internet qui ont fait des dons mais
surtout grâce à tous ceux qui ont croisé
notre chemin et qui nous ont tout donné
alors qu'il n'avait rien mais on est
arrivés sur place et on s'est dit mais
alors si on leur donne ses 3000 euros ça
va faire qui éponge et leurs dettes et
on n'avait pas fait trois mois de galère
à être à bout avoir les nerfs à vif à
manger des trucs bizarres tombé malade à
être fatigués à poireauter au soleil
dans la poussière pour éponger des
dettes
on s'est dit on voit un truc durable
alors un jour j'étais dans une salle de
classe et il ya une petite fille qui
lève la main et qui dit monsieur
monsieur séoul alaska sa question
sortait de nulle part comme la plupart
des questions de tous les gamins de 7 h
de stations et je vois le professeur qui
me regardent avec des points
d'interrogation les yeux d'un gars de me
dire je peux pas répondre je sèche donc
j'attrape le minuscule morceau de craie
et je commence à dessiner la carte du
monde grosso modo sur l'espèce dardoise
grisâtre qui servait de tableau et à
leurs avants leurs pointes et l'alaska
savoir je me retourne je leur demande
mais alors est ce que l'un d'entre vous
peut montrer où l afrique
leur silence m'a laissé sans voix
et c'est là que ça a fait tilt depuis ce
jour chip inpact est devenu un programme
de bénévolat ou des gens comme vous et
moi peuvent aller
ces quelques semaines pour répondre aux
millions milliards de questions que se
posent tous ces petits gamins parce que
nous on a eu la chance d'avoir des
parents qui ont pu répondre à nos
question d'avoir des livres la télé
internet et des professeurs des vrais
pas des bénévoles du village qui savait
tout juste lire et écrire et qui
s'efforçait de faire un programme qu'eux
mêmes ne comprenait pas parce que
finalement la générosité
c'est aussi le partage du savoir je me
suis rendu compte de la chance que j'ai
eue de grandir dans un pays où
l'éducation est obligatoire quand même
content de me retrouver dans une
université brothers ça et alors c'était
durant ce périple en afrique j'étais au
malawi et on attendait sur la route
qu'une voiture veut bien passé et dans
le champ d'à côté il y avait ce petit
garçon qui gardait ses vaches et qui
nous regardaient d'un air curieux et au
fil des heures qui passait parce qu'ils
sont passés des heures il s'approchait
gagnant un peu hanté mérité jusqu à nous
adresser la parole et dans la
conversation
je lui demande mais on est mardi
aujourd'hui et puis ce n'est pas les
vacances
t'es pas à l'école il m'a regardé avec
un sourire résigné il a hoché les
épaules il m'a dit touché l'école c'est
mon rêve
mais qui sait qu'il garderait mes vaches
et alors là dans la tête j'ai eu l'image
de tous ces petits marmots qu'on voit
tous les jours
accroché au portail de la maternelle qui
supplée maman on hurlant et en chine on
est en pleurant ne pas les laisser entre
les crocs acérés de la maîtresse
tous ces enfants qui feignent la douleur
pour rater une journée d'apprentissage
tous ces adolescents genou voile un
abonné annuellement à l'école
buissonnière et tous ces étudiants qui
se rendent en cours lorsqu'il s'y
rendent encore à moitié ivre de leur
soirée trop arrosée la veille et alors
j'ai regardé ce petit avec un mélange de
malaise et de compassion je me suis
rendu compte à quel point j'étais en
bonne santé
en continuant des gens qui ne l'étaient
pas
tous les descendants de la guerre du
vietnam qui cumule toutes les
déclinaisons possibles de l'autisme
toutes ces femmes veuves à 30 ans de
marie décimé par la maladie tous ces
orphelins tous ces handicaps et qu'ils
n'ont pas dans leur pays tous les
services et les infrastructures nous
avons nous pour pallier à nos invalidité
diverses
alors aujourd'hui je me rends compte que
je me tiens debout devant vous je vous
vois que je vous entends que je peux
vous exprimer de manière claire mais il
descend c'est un montant d'eur et que
j'ai encore quelques belles années
devant moi
potentiellement alors oui tout va bien
et d'ailleurs ce matin
comme vous je me suis levé et j'ai petit
déjeuner j'avais chantre du chaud du
froid du café du lait du jus les trois à
la fois des fruits des céréales du pain
et les croissants ou des pains au
chocolat puis comme vous je suis même
touché et je me suis même pas posé la
question de silos à l'écouler ou pas
quand j'allais ouvert le robinet et puis
j'ai même pu choisir à température et ma
convenance
j'avais à disposition du savon menthe
citron énergisante ou framboises pêche
le fraîcheur d'été puis-je aller
m'habiller avec l'arrière pensée que
tous les jours qui dit j'ai rien à me
mettre ça sur une armoire pleine à
craquer puis comme vous j'ai pris ma
voiture pour venir jusqu'ici
j'ai posté l'événement sur les réseaux
sociaux pour avoir les like de mes amis
alors avec mon nouveau téléphone que
j'ai acheté il ya trois mois alors que
l'ancien fonctionner toujours ça tout le
monde connaît et je me dis d'ailleurs je
vais aller manger alors que alors que
j'aurais même pas encore commencé à
avoir faim alors oui tout va bien et je
suis heureuse parce que je n'ai aucune
raison valable de ne pas l'être
alors là je suis pas en train de faire
l'apologie de la pauvreté je suis pas en
train de vous rabâcher l'éternel a fini
ton assiette emma qui meurent de faim
qui d'ailleurs suscite l'excellent de
réponse non mais c'est pas parce que je
gaspille pas qu'ils ont plus à manger
c'est vrai d'accord je suis pas non plus
en train de préconiser un retour aux
cavernes
je dis juste que de temps en temps il
est bon de s'arrêter cinq minutes et de
contempler notre vie d'un regard
extérieur et de se rendre compte à quel
point on a la chance j'ai surtout
conscience que je suis non seulement
narratrice mais surtout actrice de ma
vie et bien que je ne maîtrise pas tous
les éléments de l'histoire
je décide de la manière dont j'ai fait
le récit je décide délibérément de
maîtriser ma réaction
face aux émotions négatives et quand un
événement un peu contraignant survient
je me force à me poser la question
est-ce que ça entre dans sa sphère
d'influencé mathilde est ce que tu y
peut quelque chose c'est la réponse est
non alors j'essaie de me transformer en
surfaces imperméables c'est la réponse
est oui alors je m'oblige à agir pour
améliorer la situation
parce que non ça sert à rien de devenir
complètement hystérique au milieu des
bouchons
même pendant le rendez vous le plus
important du monde parce que notre degré
d'énervement n'est pas proportionnelle à
la vitesse des voitures de devant qui se
reconnaît alors ce que j'aimerais qu'on
garde en mémoire aujourd'hui c'est c'est
ce petit garçon au malawi qui était une
rencontre totalement inattendue et alors
ce petit garçon qui avait un rêve
un espoir qui pour nous était facile à
atteindre mais qu'il le minet pas il
était conscient que son action n'aurait
aucune influence
alors du coup il se concentrait sur ce
qu'il avait et sur son activité de
berger ils étaient ni haineux ni aigri
ni malheureux ni envieux ils étaient
juste là d'une douceur tendre profitant
des rencontres et apprécier le moment
présent
alors comme lui de temps en temps
apprécions moment présent sans amertume
car le bonheur on l'a en soit merci